como ya hemos visto en los vídeos
anteriores si tú comienzas con esta
ecuación diferencial logística en donde
bueno tenemos a efe que esencialmente
dice qué tan rápido estamos creciendo
cuando estamos sin restricciones por dos
límites ambientales
por otra parte aquí tenemos acá lo cual
nos dice la población máxima que podemos
alcanzar dados nuestros límites y bueno
vimos que si nosotros queremos resolver
esta ecuación y bueno claro sin contar
las soluciones constantes es nada de
igual a cero y llena de t igual a camps
entonces como vimos en los vídeos
anteriores nosotros obtenemos la
siguiente función solución y déjame
ponerla justo aquí n dt n
y bueno aquí voy a poner a t así que
déjame ponerlo con este color en el dtm
va a ser exactamente igual que bueno
primero vamos a empezar con una
población inicial en el subíndice 0 en
el subíndice 0 que es nuestra población
inicial esto que a su vez se está
multiplicando
nuestra capacidad máxima de población es
decir que esto que multiplica acá y
bueno todo esto lo tenemos que dividir
así que déjenme poner que todo esto lo
vamos a dividir entre bueno primero hay
que tomarnos la población inicial en el
subíndice 0 ya esto le voy a sumar la
diferencia que se da entre la población
máxima y la población inicial es decir
nos vamos a tomar acá menos en el
subíndice 0
camps a esto le voy a quitar le voy a
quitar n subíndice 0
ok justo con este color ok ya esto hay
que cerrar el paréntesis y todo esto lo
voy a multiplicar por la función
exponencial por la función exponencial
elevado a la menos
rt elevado a la menos a la menos r
ok que multiplica al
esto que multiplica al tiempo y bueno
todo esto es mi divisor así que déjame
hacer hasta acá esta línea de lujo y
además en el vídeo pasado vimos que esta
es nuestra función logística esta de
aquí es nuestra función logística
logística ok y lo interesante de todo
esto es que esta función no es una
solución constante que es justo lo que
queremos averiguar en nuestro modelo de
población una solución no constante a
esta ecuación diferencial logística a
esta de equipo ok y la ecuación de ver
justo y bueno ya que tenemos esta
ecuación diferencial logística y bueno
una vez que ya tenemos esta ecuación
diferencia de logística y su solución
vamos a aplicarla y justo vamos a
trabajar con un problema de crecimiento
poblacional y bueno qué te parece si
para empezar hacemos algunas
afirmaciones vamos a suponer lo
siguiente primero vamos a suponer que
estamos en una isla así que bueno
digamos que aquí tengo a mi isla es más
o menos este de aquí y bueno vamos a
suponer que empiezo
con 100 personas que por aquí tengo a
100 personas así que este de aquí va a
ser en ese subíndice 0 la cantidad
inicial de población y lo voy a poner
justo con el mismo color en el subíndice
0 es igual a 100 personas y bueno
también vamos a pensar que nuestro medio
ambiente que nos da bueno esta isla es
decir dada la tecnología actual de
agricultura la disponibilidad de agua y
bueno todo lo demás vamos a suponer que
esta isla tiene una capacidad máxima de
población de mil personas así que
déjenme poner aquí a algunas otras
personas y bueno ésta va a ser entonces
nuestro valor de acá voy a decir que
camps nuestra capacidad máxima de
población es de mil personas ok es decir
el límite de la
población y bueno además vamos a pensar
en cuanto va a ser nuestro valor de r y
para eso vamos a suponer que generación
tras generación que bueno eso es
aproximadamente cada 20 años en cada 20
años ok vamos a suponer que vamos a
tener un crecimiento del a nuestra
población crece en un 50 por ciento
entonces dejan poner decir cada 20 años
vamos a tener un crecimiento del 50 por
ciento ambiente gran ponerlo así
crecimiento
ok y es que esto nos va a ayudar a
obtener a r es decir si en 20 años vamos
a tener un crecimiento del 50 por ciento
de nuestra población
bueno dada esta información cuánto es lo
que crece nuestra población anualmente
es decir r ojo queremos saber el
crecimiento anual de nuestra población y
para esto vamos a traer por acá nuestra
calculadora que es la tengo
justo por acá y bueno con esta
calculadora vamos a ver cuál de nuestro
crecimiento anual porque si nosotros
crecemos en un 50 por ciento nuestra
población original bueno eso es lo mismo
que tener 1.5 veces nuestra población
original ya esto lo voy a elevar a am y
donde están justo aquí lo voy a elevar a
la potencia 1 entre 20 porque son 20
años 1 entre 20 y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 1.020 48
esto esencialmente nos dice cuánto vamos
a crecer poblacionalmente en el
transcurso de cada año es decir crecemos
en un factor de 1.02 1.0 2048 en un año
es decir que otra forma de verlo y si
regresamos aquí es que nuestro valor de
r que es justo con este color
nuestro valor de r va a ser exactamente
igual o bueno aproximadamente igual que
0.1 0205 si nosotros lo redondeamos y
bueno dejando poner aquí que este va a
ser nuestro crecimiento anual
crecimiento crecimiento anual
crecimiento
anual y ojo estamos contando atem en
años así que déjame ponerlo estamos
suponiendo que te está dado en años aquí
lo voy a poner te está dado en años
niños de lujo ok dado que te están años
y que ya tenemos r en el subíndice 0 y
acá como podemos escribir a nuestra
función logística correspondiente es
decir justo esto que tenemos aquí dado
lo que ya sabemos así que para esto
déjame ponerlo justo por acá n n ok
dt y te déjame ponerlo con su
correspondiente color ok lo tengo justo
aquí en st
esto va a ser déjame ponerlo con este
color esto va a ser exactamente igual
que en el subíndice 0 pero en el
subíndice 0 es 100 en el subíndice 0 es
100 esto que multiplica acá
ok pero el valor de cam es 1000 entonces
esto que multiplica a 1000 ok esto que
multiplica a mil es decir la población
inicial que multiplica a la población
máxima y esto a su vez lo voy a dividir
esto a su vez lo voy a dividir entre la
población inicial ok
es 100 ok 100 más
a esto le voy a sumar la diferencia de
la población máxima menos la población
inicial lo cual es 1.000 menos 100 bueno
eso es lo mismo que 900 así que lo voy a
poner aquí 900 que multiplica a esto que
multiplica a la función exponencial ok
elevado a la menos r ok elevado a la
menos 0.02 05 que es justo el valor que
tenemos aquí de r y esto multiplicado
por el tiempo y justo aquí está nuestra
función logística
dada esta información de lujo y para
corroborar que esta es en definitiva
nuestra función logística es decir que
esta es nuestra función que describe el
crecimiento de la población
dada esta información bueno para
verificar lo que te parece si lo gráfica
mos y para graficarlo dame un segundo
para poner
y justo la gráfica y aquí la tienes aquí
tenemos la gráfica de esta función
logística y lo primero que quiero que te
des cuenta es que cuando nosotros
tenemos un tiempo t igual a cero
entonces nosotros estamos parados justo
aquí en el valor de 100 es decir que
nuestra población inicial es de 100
habitantes y es justo lo que queríamos y
no sólo eso que después de 10 20 años
date cuenta que nosotros estamos
llegando justo al valor de aquí y este
valor de aquí es exactamente lo mismo
que 50 unidades después es decir 50
personas después de estas 100 personas
iniciales dicho de otra manera está
cumpliendo justo lo que tenemos aquí
estamos cumpliendo justo esta parte de
aquí que en los primeros 20 años esta
parte de aquí que en los primeros 20
años tenemos un crecimiento del 50 por
ciento o dicho de otra manera que el
valor de r es igual a 0.02 puntos 0 5 o
lo podemos ver como
2.200 5% que después de 20 años nos da
un crecimiento de 50 individuos que es
justo lo que vemos aquí es decir en la
siguiente generación y si nosotros nos
fijamos en la siguiente generación 20
años después bueno podemos estar muy
cerca de 200 es decir vamos a aumentar
en 75 vamos a estar en 225 y bueno eso
es nuestra siguiente generación que
estamos más o menos como por aquí y si
nosotros nos fijamos en la función
exponencial estaríamos más o menos como
por aquí en esto difiere esta ecuación
logística a la ecuación exponencial pero
además date cuenta que si nosotros vamos
aumentando el tiempo en esta gráfica de
esta ecuación logística nos vamos a ir
acercando y acercando y acercando al
valor de 1000 que es nuestra población
máxima que podemos alcanzar o bueno otra
forma de verlo es que si nosotros no
vamos a hacer tanto en la población a
nuestra población máxima entonces date
cuenta que nuestra tasa de cambio a
nuestra tasa de cambio se va a ir
acercando y acercando y acercando cada
vez más
es decir nos vamos a ir acercando y
acercando y acercando al valor de la
población máxima pero nunca lo
alcanzamos nos vamos a ir acercando
mientras el tiempo pase pero nunca vamos
a llegar a esta población máxima y bueno
además esta gráfica nos ayuda a resolver
varias preguntas por ejemplo si nosotros
queremos pensar cuántos años deben de
transcurrir para llegar al 90% de
nuestra población máxima bueno si te das
cuenta el 90% está justo por aquí y
entonces a nosotros nos vamos acercando
a este valor que está más o menos por
aquí y si nosotros ahora bajamos por acá
antes vas a dar cuenta que esto toma el
valor de 210 220 es decir tendrán que
pasar 220 años aproximadamente en esta
isla para que lleguemos hasta esta
población del 90 por ciento y bueno
doscientos diez años suena muy grande en
una escala humana pero si nosotros
pensamos una escala cósmica bueno bueno
es muy grande una escala cósmica pero
también 210 años
muy grande para una escala humana esto
pasaría después de varias generaciones
pero bueno lo que quiero que veas es que
este es un modelo bastante interesante
de hecho hasta me gustaría que fueras y
comparadas este modelo con los datos
reales de alguna isla que pase justo
esto de aquí que bueno todo esto nos da
a pie a pensar en un límite en este
límite que nos da a la ecuación o la
idea que tuvo maltos a este límite de
población máxima que podemos alcanzar y
bueno además es importante mencionar que
esta idea del límite maltusiano an ha
ido creciendo y creciendo dado el
crecimiento y la mejora de la tecnología
como por ejemplo una mejor tecnología
para producir más cultivos o tal vez
mejores leyes para que bueno pues las
personas no se maten las unas a las
otras o tal vez a un mejor control del
agua y algún plan para que el agua
llegue a todos o cosas de ese estilo y
bueno es que todo esto nos ha ayudado a
qué
del límite maltusiano crezca y crezca
más y más y más
es decir que si nosotros le
preguntáramos a thomas malthus si él
creía que en el año 2014 iba a haber
siete mil millones de personas en toda
la tierra seguramente él te diría que
eso está muy lejos de su límite más
altos ya na de este límite de aquí que
seguramente él lo habrá pronosticado
para mil millones de personas o dos mil
millones de personas y bueno este límite
ha crecido hasta siete mil millones de
personas por todo lo que ha crecido la
tecnología el mejoramiento de la
tecnología bueno el mejoramiento de las
leyes de la agricultura y todo lo que se
pueda mejorar y bueno quién sabe qué
suceda tal vez estos son un poco loco
pero puede ser que en algún momento de
la tierra llegamos a 20 mil millones de
personas y bueno tal vez eso suene
imposible dada nuestra tecnología actual
pero quién sabe tal vez si sigue
mejorando la tecnología se pueda lograr
lo cual no sé qué tan bueno sea pero
así es como son las cosas